[Música]
yo he venido muy bien acompañada esta es
mari carmen mari carmen no tiene pinta
de ponerse a generar face news verdad
diríais que con esa cara de buena
persona que tiene es una generadora nata
de fit news
bueno pues mari carmen es amiga de mi
tía isabel tiene 70 años y es de
canarias de lanzarote ella se conocieron
en un internado allá cuando tenían pues
como 10 12 años en valladolid y son muy
amigas en las últimas elecciones como ya
sabéis aquí últimamente tenemos que
herencia lo de hacer elecciones pues
mari carmen se dio cuenta de que a ella
la estaban intentando engañar o al menos
eso es lo que ella pensó resulta que
estando en lanzarote ya había pedido que
no le enviaran publicidad para ir a
votar pero sí que le llegaron los votos
por correo al menos los de algunos
partidos y lo más increíble para ella es
que esos votos estaban mal esos votos
ponían 19 de noviembre cuando las
elecciones se celebraban el día 10
la verdad es que herramientas a mano no
es que tuviera muchos pero tenía un
móvil y a ella le pareció que tenía que
hacer algo en favor de la democracia
está claro rápidamente se cogió las
papeletas y comprobó que wii un martes
no pueden ser las elecciones y entonces
generó un mensaje de texto bueno ahora
en whatsapp que envió a todos sus
contactos
mari carmen puede tener unos 200
contactos ella ha sido enfermera tienen
sus compañeros de hospital tiene también
pues a la gente de yoga a los que dan
paseos por la playa juntos también a las
amigas del colegio bueno que a unas 200
personas más o menos entre ellas mi tía
isabel me tiene isabel pues tiene
también una buena agenda ya sabéis para
enviar las fotos de los nietos y estas
cosas que es lo que hacen las señoras de
esta edad una edad muy joven por otro
lado así que lo que hizo mi tía isabel
fue mandarme la a mí y decirme fíjate lo
que está pasando a mi amiga al lanzarote
le pasan estas cosas fíjate los votos no
llegan y ya está muy preocupada porque
cree que los votos los van a
contabilizar para el partido contrario y
entonces en definitiva van a perder las
elecciones porque
en fin algo tremendamente caótico ella
no había valorado que en realidad el 19
es puramente la inversión del orden
entre el año y el mes es decir en ningún
momento había una fecha previa no había
un martes ni nada parecido sin embargo
de momento mari carmen se lo envío a mi
tía ya sus otros 200 contactos y mi tía
isabel para otros 200 y ya llevábamos
pues del orden de unos tres mil o cuatro
mil personas que estarían enterando de
esto yo le intenté explicar a mi tía que
en madrid los votos se habían llegado
con la misma fecha que no tenía mucho
sentido además que si ponía la fecha mal
te lo enviara el propio partido para que
en su voto no sirviera y bueno mi tía
más o menos se quedó desactivada aunque
yo creo que con ciertas precauciones y
sin acabar de creerme a mí la verdad así
que lo siguiente que hizo fue desactivar
a sus contactos y decirles que creía que
estaba equivocada pero no sabemos a
cuántos otros contactos les llegó por
parte de bari carmen ni a cuántos de los
que les llegó con esa cara de buena
persona que tiene se lo creería
en cualquier caso esto bueno pues es una
fe news muy casera muy casi por
ignorancia y por atrevimiento o por
intento de proteger a los demás más que
por una cuestión de querer crear una
fake news sin embargo hay mucha gente
que sí que tiene interés en crear
facebook sobre todo porque el control
que puede ejercer sobre la sociedad la
desinformación o la información falsa es
muy interesante muy atractivo vamos a
intentar repasar un poquito por encima
cómo se crean esas fake news se crean al
servicio de una idea o de una necesidad
que alguien genera y ese alguien tiene
un interés en controlarnos bien sea
políticamente o económicamente para ello
cuenta con una herramienta muy muy
potente es el miedo todos tenemos miedo
todos tenemos miedo a una enfermedad a
que le ocurra algo a un familiar cercano
a quedarnos sin trabajo
viajar en avión incluso algunos todos
esos temas son muy susceptibles de ser
utilizados para contarnos una mentira y
contarnos una mentira para lograr que
nosotros actuemos de una determinada
manera el objetivo en el fondo es que
votemos a un partido determinado o que
compremos algo que en realidad no
compraríamos en otras circunstancias o
que actuemos de una forma determinada
por ejemplo nada más sencillo para unos
antivacunas que convencernos de que esa
nueva vacuna que ahora se ha puesto de
moda o que está en el calendario vacunal
y que le vamos a poner a nuestro hijo
pequeño por ejemplo tiene más
desventajas que ventajas
el miedo funciona muy bien el miedo
además nos impulsa a actuar de una forma
muy evidente así que la razón
fundamental para crear este tipo de
informaciones es provocar en nosotros
una acción para poder luego controlarnos
de una o de otra manera como hemos visto
es muy sencillo crear una facebook se
puede crear con un móvil con un
ordenador desde cualquier parte del
mundo y además en cualquier momento
ahora la red de redes nos permite una
serie de canales muy abierta para que
podamos depositar ahí nuestra fake news
en el caso de mari carmen era pura
ignorancia pero en el caso de aquellas
personas que se dedican a hacerlo de
forma más o menos profesional y con un
objetivo claro la verdad es que tienen
suficientes canales para poder hacerlo
el último estudio que leía acerca de
esto hace un par de días decía que el 50
por ciento de las informaciones que
aparecen en la red son mentira el 50 por
ciento es decir una de cada dos bueno
intentar desvelar todos los trucos que
hay detrás de una ficción es un poco
complicado la inteligencia artificial
ahora está trabajando mucho en este
sentido y se están creando muchas
herramientas que permiten detectar
patrones que de alguna manera pues en el
texto en la forma de escribir etcétera
aprovechándose del procesamiento del
lenguaje natural y de los conocimientos
lingüísticos bastante avanzados
consiguen detectar patrones más o menos
similares en distintas etnias pero sin
embargo no es algo que sea muy muy
sencillo de hacer
por ejemplo para detectar fake news
podemos pensar en el emisor si no
conocemos al emisor y es algo que nos
llega sin un nombre muy claro pues por
ejemplo como el texto este que tenemos a
la derecha a través de un grupo de
whatsapp o simplemente en una en un
pantallazo del facebook etcétera pues
podemos sospechar de que si la fuente no
está muy clara y no nos la quieren decir
será porque a lo mejor no interesa que
se sepa de dónde vienen o también
podemos sospechar de las fotografías las
fotografías de las noticias normales
suelen tener una calidad muy buena son
unas fotografías tomadas con ese
objetivo sin embargo una fotografía de
otra fecha aprovechada o una fotografía
que ha sido modificada de forma que
tampoco está muy bien y que lo que vemos
no es un resultado muy óptimo por
decirlo de alguna manera eso también nos
puede llevar a pensar que quizá esa
fotografía ha sido tomada en otro
momento modificada filtrada etcétera de
la misma forma cuando nos encontramos
una información en un medio es
importante contrastarla con otros medios
si estamos hablando de que somos
lectores de un diario concreto y no
aparece en ningún otro
bueno salvo grandes exclusivas que no se
dan tantas en periodismo quizá estamos
asistiendo a una noticia un poco
modificada para que nos llegue de una
forma más directa de la misma forma si
no está firmada esa noticia por un
periodista por un
alguien de prestigio suficiente como
para que no le importe unir su nombre a
esa información es probable que
realmente esa información no sea veraz
también es importante que nos fijemos en
los datos los datos son unos de los
grandes aprovechados para
colocarnos noticias falsas en este caso
la cigüeña tiene su sentido como todos
sabéis quién traer a los niños
la cigüeña verdad bueno pues seguro que
todos sabéis mucho más de estadística y
de matemáticas que yo pero sabréis que
hay una serie de correlaciones que se
llaman correlaciones espúreas que se
utilizan bastante en investigación y
desde luego muchísimo en información y
en las noticias por las cuales si
omitimos unos datos o unas variables y
sacamos la relación entre otras
variables podemos llegar a concluir en
conclusiones erróneas conclusiones
espurias que nos benefician en este caso
también he dejado ahí esa noticia que me
he descargado bueno noticia ese
documento que me he descargado de
facebook esta semana en la que se habla
de la nacionalidad de unos delincuentes
pero es una noticia no tenía nada más
alrededor esa foto no tenía nada más
alrededor con lo cual no sabemos ni
dónde ha sido ni en qué momento ni
cuántos
y cuántos ciudadanos hay en todo el país
en el que se producen este tipo de
delitos es decir que lo des
contextualizamos a propósito y
eliminamos variables a propósito para
colocar nuestro mensaje que es que al
final las nacionalidades marcan las los
delitos y esto venía acompañado de la
cigüeña por ese ese artículo que de
hecho yo creo que se llegó a publicar
científico en el que se recordaba que
los lugares con más campanarios son los
lugares en los que hay más niños luego
evidentemente a los niños nuestra en las
cigüeñas no hay ninguna duda posible al
respecto y bueno pues esta es mari
carmen yo quería terminar dándole las
gracias a mari carmen y diciendo que no
os fiéis de nada de lo que os cuenten
que realmente tenéis que ser críticos
muy críticos críticos con lo que os
cuentan sobre todo de vuestro propio
sesgo de vuestras propias ideas para que
nadie la refuerce con mentiras que es
probablemente lo que está ocurriendo y
por lo que nos estamos polarizando mucho
como sociedad y como os decía estás mari
carmen yo quiero aprovechar para darles
las gracias sobre todo porque mari
carmen no existe es una creación de la
página de dispersión does not exist
que reuniendo partes de caras de
distintas personas consigue con
inteligencia artificial generar caras
como la de mari carmen que es bueno pues
muy interesante pero no existe si os
fijáis sólo hay un dato que a mí me
llama la atención después de mucho
mirarla y es que no lleva pendiente en
una de las orejas entiendo que porque en
el pastiche se les ha descolocado
gracias
[Aplausos]